Today we're going to discuss an incredibly
famous English case decided in 1893
called Carlisle versus
carbolic smoke ball law.
Students have been reading this case for
generations to learn about unilateral
contracts.
In that case,
the court considered an offer made
through a public advertisement and
contemplated whether accepting that offer
by performance also required notifying
the offer or
the defendant.
The carbolic smoke ball company ran a
newspaper ad offering 100 pounds to any
person who contracts the increasing
epidemic of influence. Uh,
after having used the carbolic smoke
ball three times daily for two weeks,
the ad elaborated that the company had
deposited 1000 pounds in a bank to show
its sincerity.
The plaintiff Carlisle Bada Ball,
used it as directed for about four
weeks and then contracted the flu.
The trial court found for the plaintiff
and the instant court affirmed.
So the central issue is this,
did the carbolic smoke ball companies add,
constitute a contractual offer
accepted by plaintiffs performance.
At this point in the course,
we have long established that a valid
contract requires consideration.
So was there consideration in this case?
The answer is yes.
The carbolic smoke ball company argued
that the contract was a new DME,
packed him a promise
unclothed by consideration,
unsupported by consideration
on the plaintiff's part.
But the three judges hearing the case,
each writing separately disagreed.
They concluded that the offer was,
was supported by consideration.
Remember,
consideration need not be a benefit
to the promise or a detriment,
illegal detriment to the promise.
He can also be consideration and here
in convenience sustained by one party at
the request of the other is
enough to create consideration.
Applying the carbolic smoke ball three
times a day for two weeks is such an
inconvenience.
This is a case where consideration
wasn't a return promise,
but was actual performance.
It's interesting that the court treated
Carlisle's payment in exchange for the
smoke ball to be a separate transaction.
Now with consideration established,
let's consider whether there was
an offer and an acceptance, uh,
which is really the subject of
this part of the course. First,
was the advertisement a serious offer or
was it like many advertisements mirror
hyperbole not meant to be taken seriously?
The court concluded that the advertisement
was not a mere puff but a serious
offer.
The court found that the
company was serious in the
advertisement itself in part
because the advertisement disclosed that
a thousand pounds had been deposited
with the alliance banks showing the
are sincere sincerity in the matter.
Next given that the advertisement was
an offer giving Carlyle the offeree,
the power of acceptance,
the court had to determine whether the
plaintiff adequately accepted the offer.
The carbolic smoke ball company argued
that the plaintiff never accepted the
offer because she failed to notify the
company that she had accepted the offer.
Under carbolic theory,
the plaintiff would have had to notify
the company before starting to use the
smoke balls quote so that the defendant
might be at liberty to superintend the
experiment unquote.
The court acknowledged that as an
ordinary rule of law and acceptance of an
offer made ought to be notified to the
person who makes the offer in order that
the two minds come together.
However,
the court continued in a case of this
kine performance is an adequate form of
acceptance and no prior
notification is necessary.
One of the judges wrote code.
If the person making the offer expressly
or impliedly intimate in his offer that
it will be sufficient to
act on the proposal without
communicating acceptance of
it to the offer or to himself.
Performance of the condition
is a sufficient acceptance
without notification.
The opinion suggests that the duty of
timely notification is merely a default
rule,
but here the carbolic smoke ball company
impliedly intimated that performance
was assists sufficient form of acceptance,
thus waving the notification requirement.
However,
if the carbolic smoke ball company had
put explicit conditions on the form of
acceptance and required
formal notification prior
to plaintiff's performance,
presumably the court would have required
the plaintiff to notify the defendant.
According to the terms of the offer,
the restatement of contracts
endorses this approach.
Section 54 of the restatement states
where an offer invites and offeree to
accept by rendering a performance.
No notification is necessary to make such
an except it's effective and less the
offer requests such a notification,
although not used by the restatement.
The phrase unilateral contract refers
to a contract that is formed by an offer
that invites acceptance by performance
of the bargain for exchange and does not
invite acceptance by a promise.
The classic examples of a unilateral
contract include an offer to climb a
flagpole for a certain amount of money
or an offer to pay a reward if someone
can find the lost dog in effect
in a unilateral contract,
the promise or exchanges a promise in
exchange for a performance that operates
as acceptance and a bilateral contract,
the promise,
their exchanges a promise
for a return promise.
Okay,
so Alice tells Bob that she'll be out
of town for the week if he Moser lawn
before she returns, she'll give him
$20 okay, no need to decide now,
Alison Sis,
if the lawn is mowed when I return,
I'll give you $20 if not,
I'll just mow it myself.
Is this an offer for a unilateral
or a bilateral contract?
Well, this is a classic offer
for a unilateral contract.
Bob Can accept the contract by mowing
Alice's lawn and does not need to notify
Alice of his intent to ahead of time.
If on the other hand,
Alison said that she needs to know
before she leaves town so she can hire
someone else.
If Bob refuses,
this would be an offer
for a bilateral contract.
Bob would be exchanging a promise to mow
Alice's lawn and exchange for Allison's
promise to pay him $20 and Bob would
be bound by his promise if he accepted
in carbolic smoke ball.
The court also had to confront a
separate issue was the offer void for
vagueness.
The advertisement did not specify a
timeline over which carbolic smoke ball
would protect against influenza after
the customers daily use for two weeks.
Absent explicit terms,
the court has two options.
Either declare the offer void for
vagueness or resolve the ambiguity.
In this case,
the court held that the offer was not
void for vagueness and instead elected to
fill in the terms to
resolve the ambiguity.
The Fort,
the court first considered
quote construing the offer
most strongly against the
person who made it.
The court rejected this contra proferentem
approach saying that it would be
pushing the language of the advertisement
too far to construe it as meaning that
a person who used the smoke ball
three times a day for two weeks,
we'd be quote,
guaranteed against influenza for
the rest of that person's life.
No to this approach would be consistent
with a penalty default rule to encourage
more precise offers.
Instead,
the court chose to fill the gap with
two and possibly three reasonable
constructions.
Since the plaintiff had used the carbolic
smoke ball three times a day for two
weeks and continued to do so
until she contracted a influenza,
the court determined that under any
of the reasonable interpretations,
uh, the plaintiff had
stated a breach of contract.
So let's review.
Today we learned that if an offer invites
and offeree to accept by rendering
performance,
no additional notification is required
to form an acceptance unless otherwise
specified in the offer.
Contracts that are formed from such
offers are called unilateral contracts.